this episode is sponsored by Nautilus go
to noddle.us slash microcosmos to
receive 15 off your membership
hello and welcome you may have noticed
that I am not one of your regular hosts
and you are correct
my name is Sarah suda and you can
normally see me over at bizarre beasts
but I heard that James our master of
microscopes had found something a little
more macro than usual and I wanted to
take a look I actually spent a good
number of years looking through
dissecting microscopes at everything
from beetles to mosquitoes and I'm
excited to see what he found at an even
greater magnification whenever we
venture together into the microscopic
world as we often do on this channel we
never fail to find both Beauty and
mystery in equal measure it pretty much
the only guarantee we have when we point
our microscope at a new sample we don't
know exactly what we'll see but we know
it will leave us Enchanted and full of
questions and the particular beautiful
mystery that we're exploring in this
episode came to us via an unlikely
Source a gang of Ruthless cats
let me explain see a little while ago
James found himself with a bit of a
problem he was keeping some wheat grains
at home to use us food for the microbes
that he cultures and films for our
enjoyment but before he could feed the
grains to his microbes they became
infested with the larvae of moths and
while James worked to find the
infestation his pet cats took it upon
themselves to deal with the situation in
their own way
what you're looking at now bursting with
color like the northern lights or the
wing fragments of some moths that were
slain by James's cats because what does
a microscopist do when they find
themselves with an unexpected abundance
of moth wings
well you guessed it they placed the
fragments under a microscope and attempt
to reveal their secrets of course but
what could be that complex or enigmatic
about something as everyday as a Moth
Wing
it turns out the wings of moths contain
many secrets that science has yet to
fully explain like for example the
reason behind this mesmerizing
fluorescence unfolding in front of us
after all you would be forgiven for
generally thinking of moths as rather
drab as far as insects go they're not
the most vibrant or dazzling of Critters
to our eyes but it turns out that
perception is more a result of the
limitation of our sight than of their
actual appearance
because under ultraviolet light the
wings of these moths glow like an aurora
both how and why this happens no one is
honestly entirely sure perhaps by
exciting the wings with high energy UV
light their scales release fluorescent
particles into the water of the sample
these particles absorb UV and re-emit
the energy as visible light in the form
of vivid greens and oranges allowing us
to Glimpse the hidden Beauty and vibrant
coloration that under normal
circumstances would be totally invisible
to us and because the wing scales
themselves are hydrophobic by Nature the
water bursts with Mists of fluorescent
particles resulting in the waves of
light we see here another idea is that
the wing scales have some sort of innate
UV reflection or absorption properties
and what we're seeing are moons of light
reflected by the deforming
nanostructures that are responsible for
those properties
see it might be surprising to learn that
the overlapping microscopic Wing scales
of moths and butterflies are actually
one of their defining features their
scientific name lepidoptera is a
reflection of this characteristic trait
it literally translates to Scaly Wings
you might have even noticed this before
if you've ever held a butterfly or moth
they might have left behind a fine
powder on your hand that powder is made
up of hundreds or thousands of these
Wing scales which we're looking at right
now at high magnification and the
intricate complex nanostructures that
line the scales of their wings have been
found to have some interesting
advantages for example they play very
strange roles in their struggle for
survival some species possess elaborate
nanostructures on their scales that
interact with sound rather than light
providing them with a form of
sophisticated
stick camouflage for tens of millions of
years they've been targeted by
echolocating bats that zero in on prey
by bouncing sound waves off their bodies
so in response the wing scales of some
moth species have evolved to absorb
these sound waves cloaking their
acoustic signature from unfriendly ears
perhaps the wing structures we're
looking at now which interact with light
waves also evolved for a similar
defensive role in this species
scattering light as a means of visual
camouflage or dazzling and obscuring the
sight of potential predators that can
perceive certain wavelengths though
unfortunately for these particular moths
it clearly doesn't work against cats but
Predator avoidance is just one of many
possibilities
lepidoptera are an ancient and diverse
bunch and their scaly wings are adapted
for a range of functions that were only
just beginning to understand
some seem to use their UV reflecting
Wings not to hide or confuse but the
total opposite to communicate like many
other insect groups but unlike us the
eyes of lepidopterans are exquisitely
sensitive to the UV part of the
electromagnetic spectrum it's the reason
why researchers and hobbyists will often
collect them by shining a UV blacklight
against a sheet of fabric drawing in a
range of species from far and wide and
various lepidopterans are thought to use
their UV perception and manipulation
abilities to Signal amongst each other
for mate attraction species recognition
and other secret messages we can only
guess the meaning of
so maybe the Aurora we're gazing at is
more like fragments of a language that
we can't decipher brimming with
information that only other moths can
comprehend but the truth is we simply
don't know for now at least the
Beautiful Mystery of this mothwing light
show reveals just one clear message we
still have so much left to learn
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you to
Nautilus for sponsoring this episode
Nautilus is the Science magazine that
brings the wonders of the universe to
your fingertips in a world of complex
ideas Nautilus simplifies science so
that everyone can understand and
Nautilus explores a fast array of
captivating topics including art
anthropology geology physics and more
renowned scientific minds and literary
Giants alike contribute to Nautilus
enriching its pages with their expertise
and creativity whether you prefer a
digital only membership or the print
edition rest assured that you'll have
full access to all the Wonders Nautilus
has to offer but that's not all you'll
also receive exclusive benefits like
Priority Access to events along with
discounts on exclusive products you can
become a member at the URL on the screen
and embark on a journey that will expand
your mind and ignite your curiosity
memberships to Nautilus seldom go on
sale but if you go to noddle.us slash
microcosmos right now you'll receive 15
off your membership
[Music]
those names you're seeing on the screen
right now are some of our patreon
patrons and they are the reason that
this show can exist if you'd like to
join them in supporting Journey to the
microcosmos you can go to patreon.com
journey to micro to get weekly
wallpapers and monthly uncut videos if
you'd like to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you'd like to see more from us there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]
thank you